There is a planet orbiting a G-type main sequence
star.
It is in what scientists call the Goldilocks
zone - capable of sustaining life, unlike
the millions of barren rocks littering the
cosmos.
And life does more than survive on this world
- it thrives there.
The large world is home to a diverse mix of
animal and plant life, including a large,
technologically advanced civilization of humans.
Aside from Earth, it is the most complex ecosystem
the SCP Foundation has ever discovered.
And it may be the greatest threat to life
on Earth in
the universe.
SCP-3003 - The End of History
Object Class - Keter
Research into this world, located roughly
208 light years from Earth, discovered many
similarities to our own world.
It is only three percent heavier than Earth,
rotates in thirty hours, and orbits its sun
at a similar distance to our own world.
The temperatures are similar, and temperate
enough so that the majority of the planet’s
land mass can support extensive life.
While few species found on SCP-3003 are identical
to those on Earth, many are extremely similar.
But three of these organisms combine to create
an existential threat.
SCP-3003-1 is a small beetle-like creature
known as “Marce” by the planet’s human
population.
While they grow only to three centimeters
at most, they have a strong ability to defend
themselves.
In addition to their hard carapace, they can
shoot a spider-silk-like substance from their
abdomen and coat themselves with an acidic
liquid to make them impossible for predators
to eat.
They spend most of their time swarming and
feeding on plants, and can live fifteen years
in the wild.
They’re largely harmless to the planet’s
humans.
That is, until an invisible enemy enters the
picture.
SCP-3003-2 is a single-celled amoeba-like
creature that has evolved solely to parasitize
on other beings, and SCP-3003-1 is essential
to its life cycle.
It makes contact with the Marce and infects
them - but it doesn’t stay there.
Rather, it starts to transform the beetles
into vicious parasites that develop a long,
pointed stinger on the head.
This stinger can paralyze its target, allowing
the Marce to inject it with the population
of SCP-3003-2 lurking inside it.
And these transformed beetles only have one
target.
SCP-3003-3 is humans.
Thirty billion of them, in fact.
The human civilization of SCP-3003 is far
larger than that of Earth, and studies have
indicated that they’re genetically identical
and could produce viable offspring with our
own humans.
And they are the primary target of the infection
of SCP-3003-1 and SCP-3003-2.
When attacked by the infected Marce, the beetle
creates a hole and enters, sealing it with
its silk material, and can live up to three
years inside the human.
And in this time, the human is fundamentally
transformed.
When infected, SCP-3003-3 becomes obsessed
with spreading the Marce, and develop a pleasure
response to being in its presence.
They maintain their intelligence, but become
hyper-rational - able to evaluate information
quickly and effectively without any influence
of emotions.
While the capacity for emotions remains, these
humans rarely express them and almost never
act on them.
They have one primary function - to spread
the infection further.
It sounds like the beginning of an alien invasion.
But the invasion already happened - and the
war is
long over.
The infection is not growing - it is already
complete.
SCP-3003 has a population of thirty billion
humans, and every single one is parasitized
by SCP-3003-1.
This has happened centuries ago, and the entire
society has been reshaped to accommodate these
parasitic creatures and to make the human
population more hospitable to them.
While these humans are identical to those
on Earth, they lack its genetic diversity.
The humans of SCP-3003 have been selectively
bred to made ideal hosts, complete with larger
bodies, more fat tissue, higher pain tolerance,
and less susceptibility to diseases.
But the society has not degraded due to the
infection.
Quite the opposite.
SCP-3003-3 has become a hivemind of sorts,
working together for a single purpose.
As such, these humans have evolved to be far
more united than humans on Earth.
They all speak a single language similar to
Dutch, with no other languages active.
All humans belong to the same culture, and
research has indicated this is about five
hundred years old.
Before the infection, they were a humble society
that had over seven thousand cultures on it
and mainly engaged in trading.
None of them exist anymore.
But they aren’t the only thing that’s
gone.
SCP-3003 lacks Earth’s genetic diversity
in animal and plant life.
That’s because in the early wave of SCP-3001-1
infections, the newly infected humans targeted
any species that preyed on the Marce.
This led to mass extinctions that created
starvation and other ecological catastrophes
- and led to a massive change in the way the
humans of SCP-3003 life.
The vast majority live in carefully planned
cities, built in the safe and temperate regions
of the planet.
The cities are mostly enclosed and are used
for industry and food growth, and are tightly
built - so much so that SCP personnel reported
feeling claustrophobic.
But one element of these cities was even stranger.
Many surfaces of the cities are coated with
a material that closely resembles the feel
of SCP-3003-1 - the Marce beetle.
The infected are so fixated on the pleasure
that being around these beetles gives them
that they use this as a form of entertainment.
The remaining members of this society live
in rural areas, in carefully planned small
communities dedicated to farming, mining,
or manufacturing.
These small pods are even more structured
than the cities.
And every area of life on SCP-3003 is carefully
planned.
Children in this world are raised communally
by large groups of workers specializing in
health and education.
They are infected quickly - at only a little
over a year old, as soon as their supervisors
are convinced they’re physically capable.
Once they are infected and their mindsets
converted to the interests of the Marce, the
children are quickly tested to determine their
ideal occupation, and steered into what they
will do for the rest of their life.
And like everything else on SCP-3003, day-to-day
life is highly structured.
Adults typically spend ten hours a day at
work, with the rest being spent engaging in
basic activities like eating and sleeping,
attending educational classes, and engaging
in entertainment.
But the entertainment all revolves around
the society’s obsession with SCP-3003-1.
They listen to recordings of the beetle swarms,
visit the enclosures where the beetles are
bred, or obsessively touch the distinctive
lumps that the parasites cause on their hosts.
Everyone fits in on SCP-3003.
There is no other option.
Any sign of divergence from one’s job function
is cause for the authorities to step in.
The first step is medical exams, to make sure
that the parasitic infestation isn’t becoming
too harmful.
Anyone who doesn’t conform to the social
standards is restrained by local members of
the hivemind and brought in for observation.
When someone becomes too old or sick to work
for society and be a host for the Marce, their
usefulness is at an end - and they are used
for organ harvesting and experimentation.
In the society of SCP-3003, one life has no
meaning - only its purpose to the hive mind.
But one area of SCP-3003’s development is
of even greater worry to the Foundation - their
technology.
SCP-3003-3 works as one, and that has allowed
it to develop technology far beyond that of
Earth.
Their planet is run almost entirely on wind,
solar, and tidal power with an assist from
geothermal and nuclear power.
Their computers have enough power to produce
data that makes foolproof recommendations
for public policy, and their artificial intelligence
systems are far beyond anything the Foundation
has developed.
Their crops have been genetically modified
to have ideal hardiness and nutritional value,
and they routinely experiment on their own
DNA for selective breeding purposes.
The planet has launched satellites into space
and visited the other planets in their solar
system.
But it’s one invention that brought this
strange planet to the Foundation’s attention.
SCP-3003-4 is a massive facility on SCP-3003
with one purpose - to open wormholes that
can transport members of the planet to any
other point in space.
Each use of this device uses up more energy
than Earth uses in a full year, and the device
seems to have one main purpose - to transport
representatives to other planets that they
would like to expand their civilization to.
The desire to spread the infection of the
Marce is a single-minded obsession for the
citizens of SCP-3003.
And they now have their sights set on Earth.
Unlike most dangerous specimens, SCP-3003
and its native species were not discovered
in the wild.
Rather, it made contact directly with the
earth through its wormhole generator, sending
ambassadors with one purpose - to spread the
gospel of their better, unified way of life
and to prepare us for joining their growing
empire.
They could have passed for missionaries - but
what they were preaching was infection with
a parasitic mutated beetle.
The SCP Foundation was not prepared for this
first contact, and collected all the evidence
they could on this strange new society.
They quickly came up with one conclusion.
SCP-3003 was larger, more powerful, and more
advanced than anything on Earth - even the
SCP foundation.
With no other option for containing the threat
immediately, the Foundation took the only
approach they could - making peaceful contact
with the ambassadors and making them think
Earth was interested in what they were bringing.
As long as the representatives of SCP-3003
think they are involved in a peaceful negotiation
for how to introduce the Marce to Earth, they
are ready to cooperate and agree to the Foundation’s
terms.
This has given the Foundation the opportunity
to study some of this society’s weak points.
One weak point, in particular, may give humans
a chance for survival.
The representatives of SCP-3003-3 do not know
how to lie.
Once they’re converted to host the Marce,
everything they do serves a common purpose
and is shared with every other member of their
hive-like society.
There is no need to lie and no purpose to
it in their society - and as such, they can
be deceived far more easily than humans.
That gives the SCP Foundation the chance to
stall them and fool them into thinking Earth
is planning for integration at its own pace.
But the patience of this strange civilization
may have its limits.
The representatives seemed cooperative at
first, agreeing to many concessions the Foundation
requested - including carefully regulating
where they entered Earth and making the Foundation
their first point of contact for their Earth
Contact and Research Committee.
This allows the Foundation to ensure no invasive
species make their entry onto Earth unknown.
Because the civilization is unable to lie,
the Foundation has convinced them that Earth
is contaminated and unable to host the Marce,
with the species becoming sterile when introduced.
The representatives seem to believe this,
and believe they are working on a solution
with Earth.
But some members of SCP-3003-3 may be becoming
more aggressive.
It was after a meeting with a representative
of SCP-3003, and Dr. Shah entered an elevator
with the alien.
Suddenly, the Marce host became aggressive,
tearing the control panel out of the wall
and stopping the elevator.
Dr. Shah was terrified, but the representative
simply said it wanted some alone time.
The SCP-3003-3 representative started speaking,
but it didn’t seem to speak like the other
members.
It was intense and intimidating.
And most worrying, it referred to taking over
a two-legged species over five hundred years
ago.
It wasn’t the human speaking.
It was the single-cell organism that puppeted
both them and the Marce.
Unlike the humans of SCP-3003, it wasn’t
fooled by the Foundation’s subterfuge.
It knew they were resisting, and it didn’t
believe the story about the planet being inhospitable
to the Marce.
It wanted the Earth to surrender and join
the hivemind, and it argued Earth would be
better for it.
No more war.
No more conflict.
No more hate.
No more poverty.
And all it would take was the complete surrender
of Earth’s free will.
And it made clear that it would win.It would
be the last thing, the only thing left in
the universe - and everyone would join it
one way or another.
It was clear that the threat of SCP-3003 was
more pressing than thought.
Which posed a question - How do you contain
a planet?
The decision to classify SCP-3003 as Keter
wasn’t hard.
But none of the Foundation’s other tactics
would apply here.
Investigation into the capacities of the planet
made clear that if a war was to break out
between the two planets, it would end swiftly
and decisively in favor of SCP-3003.
If the SCP-3003-2 living inside the bloodstream
of the planet’s humans were aware of the
Foundation’s deceptions, they did not seem
to be letting the humans of their planet in
on this - so the deception would hold for
now.
But SCP-3003 was moving fast as well - and
soon it might be too late to contain it.
Two projects in particular concern the Foundation.
One is a genetic tampering experiment to make
SCP-3003-3 more hospitable to their purpose.
It would add artificial genes to these humans,
making them consume less resources, be immune
to common pathogens, and make them able to
host ten times as many Marce.
These genes would turn these humans into their
own species.
At the same time, they are working on traveling
to and terraforming planets in other star
systems - which would make them capable of
spreading anywhere, and impossible to contain.
But the Foundation has some last-ditch plans
to stop this.
In addition to continuing their disinformation
campaign, and researching the species involved
through samples of the Marce and the single-cell
being that mutates them, the Foundation is
preparing for the worst-case scenario.
They are spreading disinformation among scientists
to ensure no additional contact is made with
elements outside the SCP Foundation, and the
O5 council has authorized studies into how
to eliminate this threat permanently.
But the Foundation will only have one chance
to do so - and any attempt will need to involve
the elimination of their wormhole device to
keep them from escaping.
Because even one specimen escaping could mean
infestation of another world - and the threat
would begin anew.
But for now, the Foundation has not deemed
any plans for an attack to neutralize SCP-3003
practical or likely to succeed.
Which means the Foundation’s focus is on
maintaining stable relations with SCP-3003-3,
convincing them that we are moving towards
peaceful integration, and continuing to learn
all they can about this strange world - as
the SCP Foundation seeks to stall the end
of history.
For more on terrifying insects, check out
“SCP-3004 - Insect God”, or watch this
video instead.